- Democrat parents
get this issue
as well as Republican parents.
This is an issue that
actually unites parents
across the board.
In South Carolina,
they were stunned by the
developments across the country
as it relates to
your ability to have
a gender identity group
and to have teachers
feeling like they're forced
to provide instruction.
That is just antithetical to
what's in the best interest
of a child, to exclude the
parent from any conversation
around those very
important topics.
And so this legislation would
pull money away from schools
who refuse to comply
with what the law,
by the way, of the
land already is.
Minors don't make
decisions in a vacuum.
It requires a parental
supervision to make
those decisions.
I have to reinforce that
by pulling the money away
so that we can make
them pay attention
to what the law of
the land already is.
(mellow music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is a senator
from South Carolina,
as well as the author
of the new book,
"America, A Redemption Story,
"Choosing Hope, Creating
Unity," Senator Tim Scott.
Finally, welcome to
the Rubin Report.
- Well, thank you, David.
It's good to be with you.
Thank you very
much for having me.
I look forward to
our conversation.
We have lots to talk about,
but the good news is I'm excited
to finally be on the show.
Thanks for having me.
- (laughs) Well,
it goes both ways.
We've been trying to get
you on for quite some time.
The schedules haven't quite
matched up, but here we are.
So let's dive right into it.
- Yes, sir.
- Because I wanna
talk about the book,
but I obviously wanna talk about
current events and election
and all of that
stuff, and you know,
some of the things you're
doing right now, but first,
the general point of
the book is positivity.
It is decency.
It is something that
seemingly everyone talks about
but nobody does
particularly well.
I include myself in that.
Sometimes I try to do it.
I often fail.
Can you talk a little bit
about how your life led you
to writing something
based in that idea?
- You know, Dave,
the "America Redemption
Story" is a book that I see
as a positive view of
the world as it is,
not as I hope that it will be.
The truth is that what I
learned through life is
that the pain that I've gone
through has helped to clarify
my purpose, that my obstacles
have become the opportunities,
and frankly, the mess
I made of my life
has become my message.
So the truth is that,
yes, it's a positive book,
but it's not one of
those pie in the sky,
hoping that something will
be different than it is.
It's the reality of what is.
There is a way for us to
bring forth a positive message
in the midst of the
chaos, and frankly,
I'm sure we'll talk
about inflation
and some of the other
challenges that we see today.
As a kid who grew up
during the Carter years,
I thank God Almighty
for Ronald Reagan.
And so the truth is
that I learned why
I love President Ronald Reagan,
because of the misery
of high inflation,
even higher interest rates,
and scarcity, not a mentality,
but at the gas pump.
So the truth is that when I
think about the hardest times
I've seen in my life,
somehow, some way a silver
lining appeared and that book
talks about that
silver lining and race.
It talks about it with
the former president.
It talks about it in winning
and losing elections.
It talks about it through
this economic challenge
that we're going
through right now.
So I find the silver
lining when it's there.
When it's not there,
I just tell the blunt
truth that it's not there.
- So, it can be tough to
find the silver lining
with so many of the
things going on right now
between inflation and
supply chain and the war,
not war in Ukraine and a
whole bunch of other stuff.
But do you think,
do you really view us in that
Jimmy Carter moment right now,
which maybe could
cause, you know,
sort of a red
pilling of Americans,
the average American
that didn't realize
that maybe big
government doesn't work
and printed money doesn't
work and the rest of it?
- Well, Dave, A, you're
right. (chuckles)
Big government has not worked.
And we have a history to
prove that it doesn't work.
Inflation is led by this one
concept that you talked about,
spending money you don't have,
buying things you don't need.
How do we prove that?
Well, $1.9 trillion on
a COVID relief package
with 1% for COVID vaccines,
that led to pouring
literal gasoline,
not literal, figurative
gasoline on the fire, right?
- Give them some time
when they're getting rid
of our strategic reserves.
- And then you go $1.2
trillion after that
in an infrastructure bill that
had 10% for roads and bridges
over the next five years.
You follow that up with
a $739 billion plan
called Inflation Reduction Act.
And it's really the
Inflation Acceleration Act.
And not only does it
accelerate inflation,
but it actually adds more fuel
to the fire by having the IRS
comb through your
file so to speak,
targeting people
under $200,000 a year.
So the truth is this is
like the Jimmy Carter years
in that gas is high,
inflation is high,
and interest is creeping up.
And that's a problem that
causes a recession when combined
with the overspending
in Washington.
- So any time I have
a Republican on,
congressman, senator,
doesn't matter, I basically
ask one question always,
which is, do you think they
are doing this intentionally?
Do you believe that they
think this stuff works?
Or is this, you know,
what people are calling sort
of like a calculated implosion,
something like that?
- Dave, that's a great question.
I can't say that the
rank and file Democrats
have a strategy to have
the economy implode
because of the
pressure of inflation,
the pressure of interest rates.
What I can tell you is that
the strategy to slow roll
interest rate increases had a
lot to do from my perspective
of people being up
for reappointment.
It had something to do
with trying to satisfy
the whims and the wishes of
the Biden administration,
and that combination,
whether intentional or not,
led to an acceleration
of inflation in a way
that we haven't seen
since the Carter years.
So I don't imagine that
they have a grand design
to completely destroy
the American economy.
I do think they have a grand
design to change the very DNA
of the American people.
When you look at
what's happening,
it's undeniable that
what is clearly happening
is this centralization in
decision making and in spending.
When you take the power and
the money and you put them
in the same place, that is
by design and that is bad
for everybody
outside the beltway.
- So when you talk to,
or if you talk to say
a Democrat governor,
maybe I just fled California,
now I live in the
free state of Florida.
- Yes.
- If you were to
talk to Gavin Newsom,
or if you have talked to him
or just one of the Democrats
who show up in New York,
Whitmer, whoever it might be,
I mean, do they think what
they're doing is good?
I mean, putting aside whether
it works or not, I mean,
just the intention.
I'm still unclear on this.
I just can't figure it out.
- Well, Dave, I have to hope
that their intentions are good.
I don't know the
mind of the person
so I try my best not to decide
whether their intentions
are good or not.
But what I can tell you
is that if you're living
in California or Illinois,
let me say it this way, Dave.
In the words of the CEO of
McDonald's headquartered
in Illinois, they
are very concerned,
not just with the taxes,
but with the violence.
They literally say people are
overdosing in our restaurants,
that violent crime is
happening in our restaurants.
If this is the Chicago
and the Illinois
that is in our future, we're
concerned that we can't stay.
That should have reverberated
throughout all of the country
and specifically in Illinois.
Governor Pritzker
should have said,
"OMG, McDonald's is now
speaking out about the crime.
"McDonald's is speaking out
"about overdoses in
their restaurant.
"Whatever I am
doing in this state,
"I should apologize and quit.
"Or if I'm not going
to do those two things,
"apologize and do
a 180-degree turn
"in the opposite direction."
Here's what we know works.
We know that rule of law works.
We know that an objective
standard for the rule of law
being applied equally works.
We know that no
bail doesn't work.
We know that defunding
the police doesn't work.
We know that creating
tribalism doesn't work.
So if we know these
things don't work,
why does Gavin
Newsom not know that?
Why does Governor
Pritzker not know that?
I don't have an answer
for what's going
through their cranial cavity.
I can tell you
it's time to stop.
- Yes, and that's why I asked
you sort of the same question
in two ways, because when
you see 350,000 people
flee California, which is
what happened last year,
you'd think Gavin might
go, "I don't know.
"Maybe this has something to
do with my policies, but okay."
- Toyota ran to Texas
from California.
I mean, Elon Musk
is now in Texas.
I mean, there are some
breadcrumbs being left
by some really smart people.
They should just pick them
up and see what they lead.
- I keep telling people,
I would've paid an entry
fee to get into Florida.
I don't wanna give that,
and now a Floridian
I'm okay with that idea, but
you know, it's all right.
So I wanna talk about
the Protect Kids Act
because you are leading on this
from a legislative standpoint
related to all of
the gender nonsense.
But before we do that,
let's do one other
social justice thing.
According to my notes
here you are Black.
Is that correct?
- My mother and my
father have confirmed
the fact, I am Black.
- Okay, well, but wait
a minute, Senator.
According to mainstream media,
you can't be Black
and Republican.
What's going on here?
- I have tried to
figure that out.
I looked at the polling
information and the polling
suggested there's 82%
chance that I'm Black,
but the chances are 100%.
Here's what's happening, and
Dave, this is really simple.
Any time an African American
who happens to be conservative
starts making
common sense on TV,
the left must nullify the
very existence of someone
they wish was a
unicorn, but I am not.
I am real.
I am not a fairytale.
I am actual really
here in front of you.
The truth is that the
most dangerous sight
they've ever seen
is someone who actually
fights for the very people
they say they represent
and produces results
like opportunity zones.
When you think about
bringing poverty
to the history of America, 2019,
think about the fact it is the
year that the private sector
invested $29 billion
through opportunity zones
in those marginalized
communities, leading
to an 8% increase
in wages, a 20% increase
in property values,
which, it shrinks the gap
between the haves
and the have nots.
And oh, by the way,
it led to the lowest level
ever recorded for poverty.
That scares the blue Dickens
out of the blue, the left.
It's a strange
thing, but it works.
The proof is in the pudding.
Black conservatives
that stand up for folks
living in marginalized
communities represent something
that MSNBC and sometimes CNN,
they just can't stomach it.
But here we are.
- They can't. You know, I
don't know if you know this,
but I campaigned
alongside Larry Elder
during the California recall
and I would open for
him at some events.
And you know, I'd read the
headlines and they'd say
all his supporters
are white supremacists
and he's the Black face
of white supremacy.
And I'm out there in
front of thousands
of people waving American
flags, cheering him on,
and they're calling them
the white supremacists.
It's like, man, you
gotta your watch fixed.
- David, here's
the funny thing is,
here's a guy who
ran for Congress
in 2010 against the
son of Strom Thurmond
in the birthplace of the
Civil War, Charleston.
And because of the evolution
of the Southern heart,
I sit now as a
United States Senator
for the great state
of South Carolina.
If we were talking about racists
not supporting
candidates of color,
I wouldn't be here, nor would
a successful Wesley Hunt,
who won his primary in Texas.
By the way, typically
Republican primaries
are more white than
the overall population.
So if you want to test the
theory of race and politics,
go to places like Texas or
Charleston, South Carolina,
or John James in Michigan,
and you start noticing there's
a trend that people actually
judge you based on the
content of your character,
not the color of your skin.
Ask Mayra Flores or Young
Kim or Michelle Steel
and you'll get the
same conclusion,
that Americans are
far more interested
in what's on the inside
than we are the outside,
but Democrats, the tribal
nature of identity politics
requires them to
start on the outside
and use these characteristics
to come to an
artificial conclusion
consistent with the
very theory of progress.
We are the land of opportunity.
We are the place where
hope breathes eternal.
- Do you think it's
possible that Republicans
or conservatives,
whatever you wanna call
right-leaning people,
was it bad messaging
on that side,
or was the messaging of the left
just so effective to
create these untrue memes
that you're describing?
Because I can tell
you as someone
that was a lefty my whole life,
came across the aisle
now, and it's like,
I meet the most
decent, loving, open,
actually more open-minded even
than the purported
open-minded people.
I mean, that's fascinating.
- Well, Dave, one of
the things I've found
to be quite interesting
is the definition
of any words used
in politics today.
Like the Inflation Reduction Act
actually increases inflation.
Or the fact that you
hear people talking
about the Republican Party
being a group of
racists or deplorables.
And the truth is when the guy
from the Black Lives Matter,
a leader showed up
at the Trump rally,
they gave him the stage.
I mean, and so they
applauded him for the things
that they agreed upon
and they didn't boo him.
They treated him with
respect and deference
on the areas of disagreement.
He was stunned.
We say in my office
shooketh, (laughs)
which is a Tim Scott
internal phrase for,
I can't believe that happened.
So literally what we find
happening all across the country
is people of good intent.
They welcome debate.
They actually
welcome disagreement.
What they don't welcome
is indoctrination.
is you telling me
that because of the
color of my skin,
I'm an oppressor or
you frankly telling me
because of the color of
my skin, I'm a victim.
Both are offensive, but
people of good intent,
they don't judge you based
on these superficial things,
they judge you based on
how the heart responds
to the crisis of the moment.
- All right, so speaking of
the crisis of the moment,
let's talk about your
Protect Kids Act.
I've done a ton here
on the gender stuff.
Obviously all the woke stuff.
First off, how did this
even get to your desk?
Is there an issue, a real issue
with this in South Carolina?
Are you just kind
of modeling this
off what DeSantis
is doing down here?
Or how did this to you?
- Yeah, I celebrate all the
governors around the country
who take very seriously
the importance relationship
between a parent
and their teachers,
and Governor DeSantis
has led on this
and we should give him a
lot of credit for doing so.
What I've seen
across the country,
I've been focused on school
choice and empowering parents
for the last nine years.
I love the model that Jeb
Bush had and Rick Scott had,
and now Ron DeSantis
has in Florida.
But the truth is that governors
throughout the country,
including Kim Reynolds in Iowa,
they're all focusing
on school choice.
And one of the reasons
why is I had this panel
and I had parents from
around the country,
one from Virginia, come down
to Charleston, South Carolina.
And she says to me, I
need basically a FOIA,
a Freedom of
Information Act request,
just to get a copy of
my kids' curriculum.
I can't get into the school.
And then you hear
these parents in Iowa
and in Virginia who are
concerned about their kids
being indoctrinated from
a gender perspective.
I decided that the problems
are not just in one state.
They seem to be in many states.
So one of the things that
makes common sense to me
is the parent is the person
who should be in the biggest,
most powerful position possible
in making decisions
for their kids.
Big labor unions and bureaucrats
are in the way of those parents
making the decisions and then
working with their teachers
to carry that out.
I want that to be nationwide,
not in one or two states
where the governors
are taking that issue
seriously, every single state.
When you're talking
about a 12-year-old,
the parents should be engaged
in the decisions of their kids.
That's just common sense in
my house, where I grew up.
I want it to be common sense
all across the country.
- When you talk to the
Democrats in South Carolina
and you bring this up and
you talk about transparency
and okay, the power
back to the parent,
do any of them get it?
I mean, again, I guess
it sort of gets back
to that other question we
talked about, but to me,
something about the one with
kids maybe is a wake up,
sort of like what we
saw happen in Virginia
with Youngkin winning
when it didn't look
like he was gonna win
just a couple weeks
before the election.
- Absolutely.
I think parents, Democrat
parents get this issue
as well as Republican parents.
This is an issue that
actually unites parents
across the board.
In South Carolina,
they were stunned by the
developments across the country
as it relates to your ability
to have a gender identity group
and to have teachers
feeling like they're forced
to provide instruction.
That is just antithetical
to what's in the best
interest of a child
to exclude the parent from any
conversation around those
very important topics.
And so this legislation would
pull money away from schools
who refuse to comply with
what the law, by the way,
of the land already is.
Minors don't make
decisions in a vacuum.
It requires a parental
supervision to make
those decisions.
I have to reinforce that
by pulling the money away
so that we can make
them pay attention
to what the law of
the land already is.
- I always think it's
funny because I remember
when I was a kid,
if they took us to the zoo
or something at school,
or we went down to DC, you'd
have to have a parental slip,
but somehow now-
- You can sign it, yeah.
- But now you can
literally talk to a kid
about gender identity privately
and hold it for six months.
It's nuts.
Senator, I should
have asked you.
I should have just
Googled before I started.
How old are you if you
don't mind me asking?
'Cause I think we're
roughly around, we're close.
- Today's my birthday.
I am 57.
- Today's your birthday?
- Yes, sir.
I said, what can I do to
celebrate my birthday?
(Dave laughs)
And the only thing I
could think of, Dave,
is to have my people call you
and beg you to have me on today.
Thank you so much.
- This is pretty sweet, man.
This is pretty sweet.
All right, so you're 57, right?
- And you're about 47?
How old are you?
- I'm 46, so we're close enough.
- 46, we're about the same.
- You're sort of, I
guess that would be like
the high end of Gen X.
I'm kind of right
in the middle of it.
But do you think the
reason, I ask though,
is because as I'm listening
to you, and as I've
heard many of your
speeches before,
it seems like the
message that you've got,
and you're literally your age,
that you are not in
your late 70, 80s,
where we're being governed
by all of these people,
that it seems like
our generation
was supposed to take the reins
and somehow we missed it.
Did something happen there
that skipped us
over in a weird way?
- You know, that's a
really great question.
I am one of the older
Generation Xers.
That's true.
I will say this,
that I don't know what
quite happened by the way.
I'm not sure if too many
were asleep at the wheel
and just missed
that opportunity.
I think we should be fully
engaged in shaping this country.
I think we have enough
experience, enough education,
enough nicks and bruises
to look back and help
those who are coming
and to look forward and to
know what we should take
from our parents and what
we left on the sidelines.
So I think we are in
the perfect age range
to help recalibrate this
country for its best output yet.
- What do you make
of the general thing
that's happening
across the country,
which is that the states
really do seem to be going
in very different directions?
I mean, I feel like I live in
a different country, honestly.
I don't mean that
to be hyperbolic.
- Well, from
California to Florida,
you move from almost a different
country, it seems like.
- I mean, literally,
3,000 miles, but truly,
it feels like a
different country.
Obviously, if you live
in South Carolina,
that's gonna feel very different
than living in New York.
COVID exacerbate a lot of that.
Are you generally okay
with that concept?
- Well, listen.
I think we've had very
unique and interesting times
in American history where
the states felt a tension
that sometimes was not healthy
and that we overcame that.
I do think we're in another
one of those moments
where we're seeing the states
divide amongst
themselves naturally.
I mean, the good news
is when you can work
and live where you want to,
you move from California
to Florida, you know,
or you should have stopped
by the way in South Carolina
and called it home.
We say those folks who
moved from like New Jersey
to Florida, and then they
come back to South Carolina,
that's what typically
happens over time,
we call those folks half backs.
They went all the way down.
They came halfway back.
So Charleston will be your home.
- Nikki Haley did
a number on me too.
It was on the list.
Honestly, I have
family in Florida
and that really was
like the final step.
- They can move up
South Carolina too.
No problem.
We have room for
your family as well.
We like red voting cards.
They're good.
- I am a newly
registered Republican
for the first time in
my life at 46 years old.
- I love it.
- All right, so
let's do a little bit
of projecting
going forward here.
Obviously these midterms
are coming, you know,
most conventional thinking
is there's gonna be
some kind of red wave.
The incumbent party never does
that well in the midterms.
What do you think
is gonna happen?
What do you want to happen?
- Well, if I had my brothers,
we would win the Senate
with about two or
three seats to spare.
We would have the House
with about, and when I came
into the House in 2010,
I think we had 63 new
seats in the House.
That was a banner year,
without any question.
If I had it my way, we'd have
that kind of a red tsunami.
What I think is gonna happen,
I think we will
control the House
at the end of this election
and there is a decent chance
that we can control
the Senate as well.
We need to execute on the field.
The game is coming down
to the last two minutes.
The score's gonna be close to
tied, and I wanna make sure
that when you give the
ball as a quarterback,
you turn and you give your
ball to your running back.
I'm hoping that
Herschel will be jumping
over the goal line in the
air with the ball secured,
no fumbles, and
wins back Georgia.
And I'm very confident
that Ted Budd
will do a four and out and score
on his two-minute
drills out there,
and I'm hoping that Dr. Oz will
be the coach on the sideline
and drawing up the
play and will execute.
He was the Harvard quarterback.
So maybe he'll scramble to
the left and hit the receiver
for a three yard score.
And then J. D. Vance, I
know he's a good author,
so I'm not sure if
he plays football,
but he can kick the extra point.
Heck, fire him
and win that race.
- I gotta tell ya, I'm
more of a basketball guy,
but the references
are all working.
I'm following.
- Good, good.
I'm about done because
I started with Herschel.
I know nothing about basketball,
but maybe we can just get J.
D. Vance in to dunk the ball
after someone else spikes it.
I'm sure you don't
spike the basketball.
- You don't spike a basketball.
All right, okay.
So if that happens,
let's say you get something
close to what you want,
even if it's not that
three senators over,
et cetera, but you
get some of that.
What do you think changes here?
What do you think
honestly changes?
- Well, the first thing
that should change
if we control both houses
is that we start oversight,
an oversight
objective to reign in
this very unwieldy
group of Democrats
running this country in
the Biden administration.
They need oversight like a
three-year-old needs a parent
to say, "Don't do this."
I mean, literally we need
to bring the
oversight hammer down.
Number two, we have to
be the party of parents.
The one thing that is manifest
today throughout this country
is that school choice
and parental involvement
is now more important than
it's ever been before.
I think it is 67% of Democrats,
68% of the Independents,
70% of African Americans,
74% of Hispanics,
80% of dual-income
working families,
all support some form
of school choice.
After looking at the
devastating learning loss
and the precipitous
drop in scores,
we have to lead for parents.
That's the second
thing we should do.
And the third thing we
have to do in my opinion
is to control our
southern border
and build a physical impediment.
It is a national security risk.
It is a fentanyl and drug risk,
and it is 2 1/2 million
illegal crossing
in the illegal immigration risk.
And finally, what is
obvious to all of us,
if you just turn
the spending off,
I believe inflation comes down
in a real and manifest way.
If you start talking about
tax policy that makes sense
and predictability in
the regulatory state,
people with certainty
and predictability,
they go back to creating jobs.
They go back to making sure
that they're making
long-term investments.
That helps to spur the
economic engines in a way
that attracts jobs
back to America
and high-tech manufacturing
and the STEM future
becomes ours.
- I know that no senator
wants to be asked this,
much less on their birthday,
but I mean the
national ambitions,
it seems like you
fit in there, man.
I mean, it just seems like the
message, the tone, as I said,
the age, it seems right to me.
- You know, Dave,
I'll tell you my
national ambition is
to travel this country
for the next seven weeks and
my home state in order to win
the majorities in the
House and the Senate.
I am a guy that, I figured out
one thing several years ago.
Applying for jobs is the
worst way to get a job.
The best way to get a
job is to do that job
like no one's ever
done it before,
and that's one of
the reasons why
in the last three weeks or so,
I've been to Florence and
Myrtle Beach and Columbia
and Charleston and
Anderson, South Carolina,
as well as Rock Hill.
And I'll be in Greenville and
Spartanburg and Columbia again
in the next couple weeks.
But I'm also in Iowa, Nebraska,
Wisconsin, Michigan,
Tennessee, Florida, Georgia,
and North Carolina in
the last just few weeks.
And I'll do more of the
same in the next few weeks
because I believe that
the most important thing
I can do with my time
and my good health
is to invest it in
the future of America
because one day
there will be kids
like yours running this country,
and we need to make
sure they start off
looking at the city on the hill.
That doesn't happen on accident.
And I think for the last
few years we thought it did.
- Is that the sort of scariest
part of what's going on,
that we seemingly have given up
just what that flag right
behind you represents?
Just almost like that.
- Absolutely.
- I know we do and the
people watching this,
but so much of the ethos of
America seems to have given up
on that dream and that
aspirational message.
- There's something about,
and I don't mean this to be
negative and I don't mean this
to be insulting, I just
mean it to be real,
this concept of being
a global citizen,
where everything is all merged
together is really unhealthy
for the United
States of America.
The thing that has
always been a part
of American exceptionalism
is not standing apart only.
It's standing above.
It's leading the world,
not being a part of it.
I want to help other
countries succeed
beyond their
wildest imagination,
but that starts by
having America succeeding
beyond our wildest imagination.
We are the standard.
When the standard
becomes average, the
world becomes subpar.
- Senator, I'm gonna let you
go, 'cause it's your birthday,
and I said a half hour
and we're right there.
What do you do on
your 57th birthday
besides hang out
with Dave Rubin?
I mean, what's going on tonight?
I assume you're getting
outta the office in a minute.
- You know I am.
I'm gonna leave the office.
I'm actually gonna go for
a little bit of a run,
and then I'm gonna have dinner
and contemplate of the future.
I love just doing goal setting.
I did it before I became
a member of Congress.
It's one of the things
I do on my birthday.
I love just thinking
about the next 12 months
and how to make my 50s
fabulous, and a part of that,
I will decide that the
next 12 months tonight.
- Senator, I hope your
predictions are right.
And I'm glad we
finally got to do this.
I hope we can do it
in person sometime.
Happy birthday to you.
- Later, Dave.
God bless you.
And congratulations on being
a brand brand new father,
maybe again, but pretty close.
- First, I'm going
to bed right now.
- First one.
There you go. (laughs)
- Thanks.
- God bless you.
- Take care.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.